kimber is with us in Charlotte North
Carolina hi Kimber how are you hey how
are you doing better than I deserve
what's up fantastic um thank you so much
for taking my call and first officers
thank you so much for that all you've
done through financial piece you have
helped me and my husband so much good
I'm glad how can I help today we have
two kids three and four months and me
and my husband both work full-time but I
sew and crochet and do other random
crafts i'd like to generate that income
out of the home and drop down to
part-time at my full-time job right now
I work in the medical field so I can go
down to PRN but I just don't know where
to start
okay all right well obviously you've got
to expand the stuff you're doing you got
to make more money in order to make that
work that's no kidding so you know that
involves really two or three things one
is you have the ability to produce more
stuff and how are you going to sell it
well I was going to open up an Etsy
account and I was going to promote
myself on the Facebook you know five
trading sulphides and all that and just
dress my kids and whatever I've gotten
make stuff for my son and I've gotten
really good responses just at the park
at chick-fil-a and wherever I am people
love it lots of Instagram with those
pictures then if he's cute right yeah of
course he's cute he's yours so uh right
yeah so yeah that's your marketing side
can you pray if you've got ten times as
many orders can you produce them that's
what I'm scared of I think I'd have to
like cap it at a certain point what I'm
thinking is I need to find like a niche
of what sells and a process that I can
perfect and well the way you do that the
only way you do that those trial and
error I mean you put out 10 10 different
products and and you look up and the one
you didn't think was going to be the big
dog starts starts wagging the tail right
right exactly and then you go Wow okay
that's the one we're going to lean on
then and um you know I've tried a
bazillion things around here that didn't
work yeah and so we've got to figure out
from there what we're going to do but
you know we find the thing that works
then we just keep loading that gun until
it's empty and so you know you know put
out ten products and find the three that
are the best and then put out ten more
and see if one of those Trump's one or
two of those or two of the first ones
and you just constantly iterating
meaning developing new different new and
different products to replace the ones
you've got and you're always looking at
the production side of it that's the
biggest thing I'm concerned about with
crafts as a homemaker moving into the
job is what are you going to do when the
volume gets up right and you got two
choices then one is you raise your
prices but the product line may be real
price sensitive so it may you know if
your orders go up tenfold and you raise
your prices you can get you can cut the
orders down right they'll drop down and
you'll make more per unit so you're fine
as long as you can produce what you're
doing but you just got to play with that
and find the price point and the
production level and the marketing
process and really in your situation
those are the biggest three things now
have you heard about this business
boutique thing that Christie right is
doing um I thought of it you mentioned
on your show I just we live it hasn't
ever come close where we only yeah we've
only done one we're doing two in the
spring here in Phoenix and in Dallas and
if there are two day events equipping
women to doing equipping women to do to
make money doing what they love and and
so this is this business it's all about
what you're doing and what a bunch of
other people do so there's people there
doing you know websites there's people
there doing Etsy stuff there there's
people there doing accounting all kinds
of different businesses that ladies are
starting and operating or coming to this
thing and learning how if you want to go
to one of those I'll give you a ticket
but you have to make a trip yeah
absolutely all right I'll put you on
hold and I'll have Kelly pick up and
we'll give you a ticket to either
Phoenix in May 13th or Dallas May 20th
either one and these events are
absolutely incredible you're going to
love it
hey you guys Rachael Cruz here I hope
you are enjoying the Dave Ramsey show
and did you know that I have my very own
YouTube channel yes that's right
kind of better than the Dave Ramsey
channel don't tell them I said that I'm
kidding I'm kidding
so subscribe and there's lots of videos
about life and money so while you're at
it if you want to check out a video then
you can check out how to do a monthly
budget it's one of the best videos out
there
you